a 9 años de prisión es la condena que ha
recibido hoy la estrella del baloncesto
estadounidense brittney griner por parte
de un tribunal ruso
es casi la máxima pena que puede llegar
a sentenciarse por tenencia y tráfico de
drogas en rusia el delito que ahora pesa
sobre sus hombros después de que fuera
detenida en moscú con aceite de cannabis
en la maleta en febrero pasado desde su
casa la asociación nacional de
baloncesto masculina y femenina le
mostraron su apoyo el veredicto y la
sentencia de hoy es injustificado y
desafortunado pero no inesperado y
brittney griner sigue detenida
equivocadamente el compromiso de la nba
femenina y masculina con su regreso no
flaquea y es nuestra esperanza estar
cerca del final de este proceso para que
ryanair regrese finalmente a eeuu
para que eso suceda la casa blanca
quiere jugar la carta de víctor wood un
ruso encarcelado en eeuu por tráfico de
armas e intercambiarlo por la deportista
y paul wiland un ex infante de marina ha
detenido también en rusia es una jugada
de la que no se sabe mucho todavía
que todo el mundo tiene conjeturas sobre
cuál es la propuesta no entraré en
detalles pero es una propuesta seria e
instamos a que la acepten deberían
haberla aceptado hace semanas cuando la
hicimos por primera vez pero mientras
rusia y eeuu juegan su ajedrez político
con los prisioneros la defensa de la
jugadora ha asegurado que apelará la
sentencia para acercar a la libertad de
esta estrella campeona mundial y
olímpica de baloncesto